what do you think about when you think
about martin luther king
um for me he was inspirational i love
the fact that he was complex i love the
fact that he wasn't perfect but i also
know that his words resonated with
many people during that time and period
and it resonates even to this day for a
lot of people
um now that's a poster that i had on my
wall growing up as well too
but i also um you know show resentment
for
uh history because you know those are
the only brands that i knew
growing up when now as a mature adult i
find that there are so many other
individuals that are out there as well
such as uh well i mean even in my high
school
in elementary we never even heard of
like frederick douglass and that's crazy
because that's like you know even now
like
we know of that right and so um his
writing he wrote what's the one book he
wrote the
uh uh he he
he's the complete opposite of victimhood
mentality that's what he writes about
whatever is the opposite of victim
admitting he says responsibility you can
make a change you can make something
happen for yourself
accountability accountability is a big
thing yeah you were telling me about
that when we spoke in
my studio over there about how you had
to look in the mirror and he said i
wasn't reading
yeah and you had to take accountability
and say all right i need to step my game
up tell us about that
well i hit a point in my life where i
was 12 years ago i was in a club in
hollywood
and everybody was having fun and the
lights were strobing and people popping
and literally you know it was one of
those moments where um
everything was moving in slow motion
like why is everything moving in slow
motion right everything is moving slow
motion so i started reflecting and i
remember something i said i just paid 20
to park and i'm in the club right now
and i have no money to even buy a drink
and you know my wife is at home and like
what am i my grown
you know 30 some year old guy while i'm
in the club right now what is my life
worth
like what what is my legacy going to be
which is why i say today the two
one of the the two top things that are
most important to me right now is
what are my three sons and my wife are
going to say about me when it's all said
and done
at my eulogy and the other component is
what
what is the legacy and the value that i
added you know while i was here
and so from that particular day at that
that night i went home and cried on
my wife's shoulder and said i've been a
failure my wife slapped me and said no
you're not get it together wow
uh we moved out of hollywood area we
moved to pasadena california i spent two
years in the pasadena public library
re-educating reprogramming myself by
myself
came out created a social media company
had 200 small businesses i was doing the
social media for paying me a thousand
dollars a month for six month
agreements and everything else is the
dynamics changed from there love that
let's go back on what we were talking
about so so frederick douglass big
inspiration who else what other names
so uh i got really into uh les brown
okay
les brown is legendary no question in
regards to
his mindset the way he thinks but more
importantly and this is why i resonate
it's through the story
right it's not necessarily just like the
bullet points of his share
it's actually the story that walks you
through his life that makes that
personal connection with you
you know the fact that my ability to
walk into projects and speak with the
kid with his pants sagging with braids
and also speak to the soccer moms but
also speak with a millionaire and
billionaires because why i've existed in
all those spaces successfully but i'll
have real experiences
in those spaces so people like that are
very inspiring
about thomas i love thomas i love him
i've been
into him for the last four and a half
years and uh it's just a different it's
just refreshing right it's one of a kind
it's refreshing to see someone think at
a higher plane like that and just kind
of like pushes you to be
a better self so so martin luther king
he was a registered
republican right who would have mlk been
today
so bring him to today who would he have
been
so imagine all the protesting all the
writing that's going on the looting the
business all the stuff that happened in
who who would he have been out there
campaigning today that's a good question
um i believe would he have been
supportive of the blm movement
no he wouldn't have been supportive i
don't think so he would have been
supportive of black lives matter yeah
absolutely as a
name as a as a you know but not what
not the organization in their mission
statement he wouldn't be for that
are you i'm i'm for black community i'm
for our lives matter you know so
break down the difference as being a
black man who's you said seen all
sides of the track and you can speak to
anyone what is blm what is the black
community give us as a father
you know everything package it all up
well the black community
is very simplistic it's just the black
culture it's the black community when
you
you know the black the blm is kind of
it's an organization so it's a separate
entity that you can actually join to be
a part of
that you bought into based upon their
ideology the process and things that
they produce or don't produce
of course we find out there's a lot of
things that they don't produce in
regards to the money that they've raised
because they haven't put back into the
black community and the culture
but for me i can stand beside someone or
organization or group that has that
mindset or the structure with their
with their mission statement and i think
it's uh i think it's a very divisive
tool
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye